the story of Agnes and Clara boric and
their family could happen in your towns
right next door to you it could happen
to the rich man and to the poor man the
office worker or the farmer a white man
or a negro it could happen to the young
and it could happen to the aging it
could happen to anyone
it is the story of a willful man who
refused to believe the truth because he
stubbornly and perversely rejected the
truth he brought tragedy to those
closest to him he turned a deaf ear to
experienced men of Medicine who sought
to help him in his fight against
tuberculosis instead he chose to rely on
the advice of charlatans and quacks it
is the story of Peter Borik and the
heartaches he brought his daughters
Agnes and Clara the story opens on a
tender note for Clara and Johnny Carson
a young farmer who manages the Borak
farm in his spare time are in love they
hope to be married soon Johnny is her
childhood sweetheart his regular job
before he took over operation of the
Borak farm was driving a milk truck for
a large dairy company nearby he still
does this when he is able now however
Peter Borik is bedridden most of the
time and unable to work Johnny and Clara
unaware of what the future holds for
them faced life happily secure in their
loss hard-working mrs. Borik Peters wife
lives for her children alone a kind
yielding woman she is resigned to a life
of drudgery and ever constant fear that
Clara and Agnes and perhaps Johnny might
fall victim to the disease that Peter
Borik carries it's time for lunch and
johnny has been invited to eat for the
family Peter cannot leave his bed he
will not go to a sanatorium he does not
believe tuberculosis is catching
he believes he can get well by staying
in bed
he wants to be near his neighbors so
they can drop in and see him
he likes mrs. Borik cooking he wants to
be home so he can call his wife or his
daughters at any time of the day or
night
the father's absence at mealtime is
evidence but his influence both physical
and spiritual is felt by the entire
family every time they eat the door
beyond the kitchen stove leads to his
room from that room he can hear the
familiar voices of his family at one
time he was in a sanatorium he was not a
cooperative patient he felt there were
too many restrictions that he did not
feel sick he left against medical advice
and since doctors cannot force patients
to remain in a sanatorium he could not
be stopped when he left the sanatorium
he left behind proper medical care
professional nursing attention and the
rest routine which is so essential to
the tuberculosis patients through his
ignorance he left behind all hope and
brought home a disease were just to
bring immeasurable sorrow to his family
Peter's presence in the Borak household
has not changed the whole making routine
although it should have to ensure
protection for the family dishes used to
serve his food are mixed with those used
by the rest of the family his bed linen
goes in with the family laundry the
handkerchiefs he uses contain sputum
which is contaminated with tuberculosis
germs the germs spread from person to
person and cause tuberculosis Peter
refuses to believe their simple facts
like measles chicken pox or scarlet
fever tuberculosis is contagious
except for Peter Borik the Borak family
looks healthy they feel well they don't
think they can catch Peters disease they
don't know a person may have
tuberculosis for three years and never
have any symptoms in recent weeks Peter
Borik sin creasing lis bad condition has
intensified his stubborn streak he
talked to his family all the in
irritable command his raucous coughing
has increased the room behind the
kitchen
toll has become a self-imposed cell from
Richey bars time tried methods of
tuberculosis cure his failing condition
is reflected in his lack of appetite
each day he leaves more and more food
untouched on the plate which mrs. Borik
serves him three times a day but
tuberculosis workers know that Peter
Borik left the sanatorium against the
advice of physicians they have been
watching his case ever since he acted
against the advice of specialists in the
field of tuberculosis cure and
prevention now they hope they convince
him to return to the sanatorium ever
alert for cases such as these
tuberculosis workers are certain that
Peter Borik will return in order to
protect his wife and daughters courteous
and professional the tuberculosis worker
visits the Borak household this job
requires tax or she does not want to
frighten Peter Borik back into the
sanatorium she must convince him and
mrs. Borik that he is spreading
tuberculosis to his family and friends
that he'll be able to receive visitors
frequently in the sanatorium but mrs.
Borik will have none of this she is too
familiar with the wrath of her husband
and with his ideas of sanatoriums
mrs. Borik keeps the visit of the
tuberculosis worker a secret both from
Peter Borik
and from her children that's why Johnny
and Clara go ahead with plans to get
married each new day brings to them new
happiness as they plan for the future
they are ignorant of the cloak of
disease that is enveloping the Borak
household and their lives for how long
can the human body stand up under the
strain of bombardment of the
tuberculosis germs these to use vigorous
and gay appear to be happy and healthy
as they await the day of their marriage
but are they healthy the tuberculosis
germ has used them for targets back in
the borg household they had been exposed
for months to the germs discharged by
Peter Borik
is one or both to be a victim perhaps he
had come in contact with tuberculosis by
touching an article contaminated by
Peter Borik
in the spring Johnny and Clara are
married Peter Borik is too ill to attend
the church ceremony but unknown to all
the mark of his willfulness is with them
it is a threat to their happiness that
could have been avoided if Peter had
gone to the sanatorium sometime before
in fact if Peter had listened to sound
medical advice or if his wife had acted
upon the suggestion of the tuberculosis
workers he might have been cured by the
time the wedding took place as Johnny
takes Clara for his wife and promises to
protect her in sickness and in health
little does he realize that she had
lived with open tuberculosis in the
household whether or not she has escaped
this attack remains to be seen their
friends are equally ignorant of what is
going on in the Borak household they can
see only the beautiful bride and the
dashing handsome groom two healthy
vigorous young people who are now man
and wife
back at the boric household usually
somber and quiet the borax and their
guests gather for wedding festivities
everyone has visited and paid his
respects to Peter Borik in his sick room
preparations are made to have the bride
cut the wedding cake little does the
happy couple suspect that this ceremony
is the backdrop for the tragedy that is
to follow but Joanie and Clara are
unaware of the danger as they take over
the operation of the boric farm where
they now live his life with Clara is a
happy one one day more than a year after
their marriage Johnny comes home from
the fields to find that Clara is not
feeling well
he questions her and finds she is
suffering from headaches he comes
fatigued easily and is running a slight
fever Clara then tells him she is going
to have a baby and Johnny attributes the
illness to the coming child
but as time goes on Johnny wonders could
it be that in some mysterious manner
Peters disease might be causing Clara's
illness Clara symptoms grow more evident
daily she tires easily the fresh farm
foods cannot temperature appetite
johnny has made a decision he is no
longer satisfied with Peters advice that
Clara eat lots of food and stay out in
the fresh air Johnny wants Clara to go
to a competent doctor he fears for her
life and that of their child Clara has
just had an x-ray of her lungs and a
physical examination for tuberculosis at
the sanatorium the x-ray film seen in
the viewer reveals she has fallen victim
to the disease the sanatorium doctor
explains that everyone should have a
chest x-ray each year he tells mrs.
Borik that tuberculosis is not inherited
that it is not caused by weak lungs he
points out that it's spread by germs
from one person to another and it runs
15 times higher in families where there
is a history of tuberculosis the doctor
Ponder's he wonders where Clara could
have contacted tuberculosis he tells
mrs. Borg that one does not have to look
sick to be sick with tuberculosis the
doctor also points out that the earlier
tuberculosis is detected the easier the
disease is secured the body must build
up a resistance to the germ Clara has
far advanced tuberculosis if you'd only
come to a doctor earlier if you don't
even check periodically for tuberculosis
how he asked mrs. Borik could Clara have
caught a break you know sirs mrs. Borik
knows now sadly she recites the story of
Peter for the first time
Peter her husband was in a sanatorium
for treatment but Peter didn't like the
sanatorium he didn't feel sick he didn't
realize that he should be willing to
remain hospitalized so that his family
would be protected against the disease
he didn't believe what the doctors told
him one night Peter left the sanatorium
Peter Borik left the sanatorium against
medical advice
the full impact of Peters willfulness
his persistent rejection of the truth
has come home Johnny wants Clara to go
to the sanatorium he feels that both her
life and the life of their child might
be saved
he knows if she'd gone earlier she would
not have to stay so long in the
sanatorium but Peter has taught his
lesson well Clara too rejects sanatorium
care she will take her chances of
getting well at home her father had told
her that once you enter the sanatorium
you would surely die poor Clara she
believes this wrong advice
what better attention could she get in a
sanatorium she asks herself and her
husband but she has no way of telling if
she is getting better or worse at the
sanatorium she would be x-rayed
regularly sputum tests would be taken
surgery would be recommended if
necessary the progress of her disease
would be noted regularly
Jonnie begs Clara again to go to the
sanatorium complicated by the fact that
she is expecting a baby
tuberculosis works quickly in Clara she
loses ground rapidly
director doses takes its toll and with
Clara's death and other life has taken
the life of her unborn child Clara has
paid with her life
johnny is not very expressive but he
misses Clara terribly it had so little
time together none of their plans the
plans of youth had come to fruition
he remembers her vivacity here winsome
smile her dark curls and her tender
touch
he realizes that all this has lost to
him forever because of a disease which
need not have happened if it had not
been for one man's willfulness
and in remembering Clara and her youth
he thinks of Agnes who has gone to work
in a factory will the pattern of tragedy
be repeated in lively Agnes who has such
a desire to live johnny has talked to
the tuberculosis worker she has urged
Donnie to prevail upon Agnes to have a
chest x-ray she pointed out to Johnny
that tuberculosis takes its greatest
toll among young people from 15 to 35
years of age Johnny tells Agnes this he
asks her to have an x-ray after all he
reasons if you find out that you haven't
caught tuberculosis from your father or
Clara you'll have nothing to worry about
if you do find out you have tuberculosis
you can go to the sanatorium before your
case becomes hopeless he tells her that
many people have a tuberculosis germ in
their bodies as long as the resistance
is kept up the germ remains inactive he
told Agnes she's been working hard at
her factory job but the Jeremie have
gotten a foothold in her body
he reasons with her but Agnes can't be
reasoned with she has a streak of her
father's willfulness in her it is faith
she decides if my father is sick with
tuberculosis and my sister died from it
I will - it's just a matter of time and
I might as well enjoy life secretly
Agnes feels that she too might have the
disease
many thousands of tuberculous sick are
among us everything they touch cough or
spit on is infected with eatery ketosis
germs they're a constant source of
danger to the people who come in contact
with them bus they go blithely on their
way either unaware that they have the
disease or unwilling to do anything
about it
Agnes is afraid she does not want to
know the truth
but the truth cannot be denied and shut
out forever it must come up and Agnes is
five her stubbornness cannot refuse to
acknowledge that she is sick
too sick to work efficiently
many industries have case-finding
programs industry wants to protect its
workers against tuberculosis an x-ray is
painless and takes only a moment
x-ray is used to find tuberculosis among
apparently healthy people as well as
among persons who have had contact with
a tuberculosis patient they find her
disease in the factory x-ray and as is
true in industry when tuberculosis is
found she is required to leave her work
Agnes has tuberculosis no longer does
mrs. Borik need to be convinced
tuberculosis killed one daughter and she
is determined to save agnes mrs. Borik
will defy peter at any cost
knowing that his ignorance has caused
this tragedy she is going to have a
chest x-ray herself Jonny will have one
too Agnes has finally reconciled to
going to the sanatorium she sees that
her father is not getting any better at
home and that Ferrer came home only to
die she realizes that if she gives up
six months of time now to sanatorium
treatment she may well save her life
happily Agnes's disease has been caught
early she will be able to recover from
tuberculosis and lead a happy normal
life she now realizes tuberculosis can
be cured it is not a death sentence mrs.
Borik knows and Johnny knows that by
going to the sanatorium early Agnes's
chances for recovery are enhanced johnny
and mrs. Borik returned to their house
of sorrow determined that there shall be
no more needless suffering and death
they have been examined and they happily
are not victims of Peters disease it
will not be a simple matter to return
Peter to a sanatorium but their minds
are made up they know he is wrong in
staying home he must go back to the
tuberculosis Hospital last year more
than 50,000 American men women and
children died in our country because
they made the wrong decisions when they
still could have been saved
don't let the tragedy of the Bork family
repeat in your home remember no home is
safe until all homes are safe